Well, this is what a well worn
copy of white tiger looks like.
The
style of it
is pretty striking.
Anybody want to take a shot at
other novels that reminds you of
yes content
and not to cover.
Okay.
Well it reminds me of,
it reminds me of someone. Rashid has
been nice children. Okay. That's,
that's one interesting
suggestion. Sophie Quinten. Yes.
Yeah.
What do you think?
Um, what do I think of the book or is this
related to the warm call email and you
send it the morning? Yeah. Well, um,
in the back of white tiger they sort
of a reading group discussion with the
author and one of the things the author
says that it's kind of interesting is
that, um, his inspiration
for Ballarat was, um, it, it,
he sort of a compensate the character
that came out of the author's experience
just hanging out in slums and train
stations and in servant's quarters and
listening to what basically the underclass
of India are saying and how they are
thinking. Um, and it sort of,
it's interesting that ballroom who's
such an angry character is the embodiment
of something very real. That
Attica Adiga I guess, um,
felt talking to people on the street.
Right. Okay. That's good. Um, in the,
he also mentions three American
novelists in the, in the back.
Did you notice them? No, I did not.
Okay. Um, well it's interesting.
The um,
are
the influences on white tiger or three
black American writers of the Post World
War II era, Ralph Ellison, James
Baldwin and Richard. Right.
So, um, it has,
um, are many ways to look at it. It is
written in a very
straightforward style that is,
each paragraph is pretty straight forward.
The sub text about how it's being
told is a little more complicated.
And one of the other things she
says in the, in the back, which,
and this goes to the point Sophie made,
uh,
is that while,
none of the characters or incidents
are copied out of journalism,
which is the authors business.
Uh,
all of them are meant to be representative
of something real in Indian wife.
So that the book is literally fiction,
but has a purpose,
like many of the best works of fiction
as a purpose of describing something,
uh,
that is very real.
Are there ways in which fiction can
do a better job than social science of
telling the truth about a country?
Anybody got a thought about that?
Yes.
Well, it's an art form and something
like social science can't really say,
well this makes me feel this or
this is like the nuance of that.
And that's where art plays in.
And I mean, I'm also, I mean,
it's mass media too and a lot of ways so
you can reach a lot more people through
this and have it easily understood,
okay,
it's mass media,
but it actually does something that most
nonfiction written by academics can't
do. Right? Economists,
political scientists,
people like that by and large,
a little wooden than religion,
a little category bound,
a little obsessed with methodology.
And this book covers a huge swath of a
very complicated aspects of a society,
which,
uh,
as far as I can tell his top half dozen
in the way of complexity in the world.
Right.
I mean the structure of the historical
structure of India and the incredible
rate of economic and Sociological
Change, uh, have very few,
uh, equals elsewhere. Um,
Divia if I got that name
right. Yeah, yeah. Um,
again,
and again,
the concept of out of the
darkness comes up in the book,
help us try to understand that.
Yeah. So I think it's sort of literally
and figuratively the darkness of India,
the parts of India that has sort of been
left behind and all the development and
globalization, um, where
there's no electricity.
So like literally it's dark
when the sun goes down. Um,
and where there's also a lack of like
basic necessities like sanitation,
like proper food.
Um,
and I think also the darkness of sort
of corruption and bribery and like
theoretically there being resources,
but those getting funneled into
the hands of like, for example, um,
like the great socialists who is,
you know,
campaign to sort of lift the
darkness out of the darkness,
but ended up just getting sort of sucked
into the bribery of people in the upper
caste and the town. And, um, continuing
to take advantage of like the lower caste.
Okay.
From the point of view of a
village India deepen the darkness.
Uh, is it clear one way or the
other, whether the economic
miracle and maybe too strong a word,
but the incredible progress overall
development that's been made since about
1990 is a good thing or a bad thing?
I think like,
I think it's,
it's kind of goes both ways and I
think he talks about it and that, um,
I guess he sort of talks about it as
the difference between the north and the
south or what like his, the
two cities he was in. Um, it,
when development gets kind
of entrenched in corruption,
that ends up being a bad thing and ends
up taking advantage of people at the
bottom.
But I think to me it seemed a little
optimistic that it can be a good thing in
places where it's been done properly.
Okay.
And do you have it in the back of your
mind an idea or two about what doing
capitalism properly mean?
Well, not really. I guess I'll Betcha.
Do you know not corruption?
Not Bribing policemen.
Okay. Not Corruption, not bribery.
I mean,
I don't know.
There are, I guess a lot of things, but,
okay. Let's go on and we'll find of,
okay.
Uh, Sudhir yeah,
there's a passage in,
I think it's the first night in the book.
How about,
uh,
I think it's for animals, my
right, who represent people.
Can you help us with?
Sure.
I think the first point is that a,
do you guys making a statement about a,
and quite unabashedly
landowners is animals, uh,
who in this case quite literally
feed off Lakshman guards,
physical and human resources.
Um,
the other obvious point is
that the animals that do
you get chooses to represent
the landlords aren't
particularly glamorous.
I think he has a view of land
and is tocky cross lazy. Um,
and it's clear that,
you know,
one of the few reasons or main reasons
that they hold a position of power in
society is they've probably descended
from families of landowners who have a
long history of exploiting
and extorting from the war.
Okay. Now here's an interesting
parallel. If you think about the,
about Clark farewell to alms.
Uh,
one of the big lessons there is
that land is the primary basis of,
uh,
economic return in premodern societies
and loses its relative standing with
development.
So if a degas is right,
are the stork, the Raven, the wild boar,
and who else? Oh, and the Buffalo, uh,
are they basically fossils of a previous
era grasping for the last straws of a
power base?
It will go,
or given the nature of rural India
will lay persist in that position.
Generation after generation,
you think,
you know,
it's hard for me to kind of identify
that trajectory of India's development.
She says, I don't know
how much of, I guess,
I mean really and yet is large,
makes a large chunk of the, uh,
the country and the economy for what it's
worth. So I think there are probably,
um,
in the foreseeable future,
there's probably a very good chance that
characters like these four will still
retain a good deal of influence in
those spheres. I mean, obviously, um,
you know, corporations are
making their way into these, uh,
into rural areas and setting
up innovation camps and, um,
large offices. But to the
extent that India has, um,
uh,
the rural base is strong,
I think these people will thrive.
Okay. And if, uh, if capitalism
seeks economies of scale as it's
wanting to do a small landholding,
uh, will be, uh, eventually, uh,
undermined by large scale land
holding and agricultural development,
uh, on a vast scale or that's, that
would be the textbook hypothesis.
Uh, if you look at what's
happening in Brazil, for example,
a development on the scale of farms,
uh,
25 or 35 miles square,
25 by 25, say, uh, is commonplace.
And maybe India is different.
And the reason it may be
different is that the indigenous,
the density of indigenous rural
population is much higher.
And, uh, the,
the process by which
land would be aggregated,
it may happen quite a lot slower.
Maximillian uh,
where the title of the Book Come
From and how do you understand
he calls it the white tiger because,
um,
by Ron stands out of all of the other
servants, like why Tiger stands out. Oh,
by tiger stand out of there.
I don't know other animals who are
not albinos because they're so rare.
And,
um,
there's one incident leading up to
becoming the white tiger that is,
I guess where they are on the wait with
the two sons of his masters to bribe the
minister. And, um, I run, reaches out to,
um,
to a beggar intuitively to help him.
And he gives him some money and the
sons of his master get really angry with
them. Um, I'm giving him the money, um,
and they start to complain about,
um,
how Texas they have to pay you and that
they're already helping the poor. And um,
yeah, that's how he realizes
that the entrenched,
entrenched inequalities in Indian society
will perhaps persist despite India's
new prosperity.
Okay.
Go ahead.
And do you remember the part about the
school house early on where there's a
surprise inspection?
Does anybody remember this?
I drawing a blank here over there?
Yeah. Um, in the beginning I believe in,
there's a surprise
inspection and he's, uh, uh,
the inspector comes in and
asks the students a bunch
of different questions and
really nobody is able to give any, uh,
any good answer except for a ballroom.
And a,
he then asked him,
I guess he asks him about
a certain question. I bill,
I forget exactly what the question is,
but the answer was that it's
a white tiger. It's a think
that is the most unique.
Okay.
So he gets named white tiger for being
uniquely talented in a situation where
talent is not being developed.
Right.
And how does the school school
room operate? Do you remember that?
Well,
it's interesting that ball armed and
actually blame the teacher because I guess
the teacher would steal the uniforms
and all the resources that came.
But I think at one point farm
even says like, well, I mean,
no one really blames him because his
payment also gets taken by someone else.
Um,
so the teacher,
there's just like a chain of corruption
that ends in the teacher basically
stealing the resources that were meant
for the kids and just sleeping all day or,
um, and while the kids do whatever. Okay.
No,
quite often there's a mention of the
fact that the teacher was snoring. Well,
right. The students were supposed to be
learning somehow from one another. Uh,
and you're right in that the,
I think the narrator says something like,
um, those who live in a dung heap
can't be expected to smell well.
Right? And so there's a kind
of environmental explanation,
um, social and social
environmental explanation.
And W why do we think is
this, is this, uh, uh,
man bites dog story or is corruption of
a fairly major issue in Indian society?
Who's got an opinion
back?
I,
yeah,
I think it's a fairly major issue because
even when you make the transition into
like the lightness in the book, you still
get severe corruption of course with,
um,
you know,
the ballrooms boss going to give the
big bags of money to the government. Um,
so I think it's corruption that pervades
every level and kind of the light is a
little bit of a deceptive name for what
ballroom moves into because even at the
height of his success,
the only way he can succeed is by
killing someone then by paying off the
policeman.
Okay. Now that's, that's elegantly put,
but it's evidence from
fiction about fiction.
So what the judgment I'm looking for is,
is his claim that the book represents
Broglie truthful patterns in the society
or not you buy it or not?
Well, I mean having, um,
India myself several times and
having many friends from there,
I definitely heard, you know,
considerable, um, stories
of corruption. I mean, I,
I'm not in a position to
judge the society as a whole,
but it seems like it would
have an element of truth to it.
Okay. Has anybody glanced at one
of the world rankings from say,
Transparency International
or other organizations which
have VAT evaluate levels
of corruption?
Okay.
The Socratic method stops here.
Uh,
India is near the top of the world
table in a corruption as a per an issue
perceived by people in
business as problematic.
Anybody with substantial experience,
one of contradict or
elaborate on this point?
Oh yes,
we need a mic in the middle
for lots of people staying in India,
especially doing the sister
corruptions almost become a VA light.
So they see, they'd rather call the
system, flexible them calling it corrupt.
So if you want to get a
government sanction, which
was only take three months,
you can get it done in three bay,
three days if you pay an additional
amount and that's the premium that's a
pregnant, that's not corruption.
So for a lot part of the society,
it's a flexible system
rather than a corrupt system.
Okay. And a good American
economists would call it
the inefficiencies in the market.
So you just exploiting them. Yep.
Inefficiencies due to rent seeking,
right.
Rent seeking.
I love that concept.
MMM.
Danielle. Right on the w
are you hear Danielle? Hi,
I'm Dr Ram.
Pondi is it Pindi something like that.
Something like that.
Tell us about that incident in the book
and give us something about what you
think it means.
Okay, so I'm on page 41 of the book,
the theirs when they're all sitting,
um,
in,
and the white tiger has taken his father
to the hospital and they're sitting in
the waiting room waiting
for a doctor who won't come.
And an old Muslim man start songs story.
Um,
excuse me about this fictitious doctor,
doctor ran panty and talks about how
the great socialists sells off plots of
like, um, like districts to
doctors and the doctors, bodies,
districts almost like a feudal system.
And then the doctors in
those districts will,
he'll take part of the salaries from
these doctors and then tell them, oh,
well now you can just go off
and work for a private hospital.
You don't have to worry
about these people.
I'll write it down in my
ledger that you've been there.
So basically the government is on a
totally different strata and all the money
or benefits just get written down or
written away and these people are left
dying or with wounded
legs like the Muslim man.
And he's just sort of laughing about
it. So there's this sense like, um,
with the Muslim man and all
the people in the waiting room,
this sort of laughing about their,
their problems or grinding about them
because I mean his father dies in the end.
Um, ballrooms father dies in the end
because this doctor never comes. So the,
the corruption and the resources are just
like
strewn about and
that passenger is actually quite
polemic all the way it's written, right.
It probably overstates right.
There were probably a hell of a lot of
places where you actually can see the
doctor and the doctor does pay attention
to people who were supposed to pay
attention to.
But the general pattern described there.
What's wrong with corruption?
Corruption.
I mean there,
there are various is people who think
corruption is not altogether a bad thing.
For example.
MMM.
There are people who write
about American cities and say,
if you have to choose between corruption
and civil service bureaucrats who do
everything to the letter of the law,
take corruption.
MMM.
An example is a historical example was
the Fulton fish market in New York,
which was run by the mafia for a long
time and read pretty efficiently.
I mean, there was some rent
seeking, uh, and some violence,
but it worked.
And then Rudy Giuliani took it over
and put in clean bureaucrats to run it.
And people thought, well, it may not
actually run as well this way now,
but there is, there's
counterpoint to that. There's a,
there's a big themes about why corruption
is from the point of view of growth
and development and human welfare.
Probably not on average a great thing.
Did you have a comment? Well, you know,
we can always go back to Adam Smith
and disregard, but, but not what he's
most famous for. But he, he's, he, he,
he kind of gives us a self interest,
but it's not this naked isolated
form of self interest. You know,
he said capitalism only functions upon
a foundation of ethical participants and
if not,
it's brutally,
grossly inefficient because you can't
get the right information around at the
right time.
Terrific. Right. And this is, I mean,
this was a huge point in understanding.
Smith Smith is a moron,
right? Smiths in his own time,
his famous book wasn't this,
it was a theory of moral sentiments.
And Smith is saying
articulate shelf interest,
frankly pursued within a framework of
honest communication within a framework of
honest communication and with a
government in the background that enforces
contract and prohibits
fraud within that framework.
Self interest creates an
upward draft on an economy.
But if you take away that framework,
the ethical aspects of,
of people's beliefs and the proper
functioning of the government in enforcing
contract and related things
and you take all that away, uh,
the,
the invisible hand story works if anything
in reverse and we're inclined to just
assume that,
um,
to, to just march too quickly by, uh,
the issue of that fuck,
that foundational issue and the eye.
If I asked you this, how many of you've
done Ben pollocks course on Game Theory?
That's really, I recommend
it to all of you. Um,
but think,
think this or think about this problem.
Suppose you are operating in a system
where everybody else is willing to lie in
order to profit.
And at each one of those other people
assumes that about all the people she and
she or he is dealing with,
how do you form a strategy
to make a business run?
And the answer is that it is virtually
impossible because you cannot anticipate
the way people,
people respond to straightforward
incentives and it's a big deal.
And getting out of that,
out of that dilemma,
right. [inaudible] another way
to put it is there's a famous uh,
philosophical example, one version
of which is a sentence, you know,
written inside a box which says this
sentence is a lie or the sentence in this
box is a lie.
Okay.
How do you interpret that? True or
false? False. True. True. If false
can't get anywhere with that.
Very hard to live that way.
Mid back
caste is a
really complex cultural structure,
which I've read a little about and
talked to Indians widdle about and it's
obviously important.
Help
help the uninitiated here.
I'm a little bit
sure. Um, I did some research last
night, but I think I got my most,
my most profound revelation.
I talked to one of my best friends from
Indiana and he gave me an incredible
perspective on cast and most of the
donors and Dell, but I didn't know about.
And so I'm going to go a little bit
into the history of cas because it's,
it's honestly fascinating.
Um,
cast actually started out as a really
advanced complex system that we see in
today's capitalist worlds.
It started off as division of Labor
started off as promoting specialization.
Cast a cast wasn't a bad
thing when it first started.
It just means that people were specialized
in certain traits. For example,
we have blacksmiths and we
had traders and we had, uh,
people in different sectors of
the economy here. Similarly,
we had castes in India and they weren't,
they weren't silent constraining.
They were just indicating what you
are best at its division of Labor.
So cast actually started degrading
or unfortunately, and it's actually,
it's actually gone through some evolution.
Uh,
and this catalyst when the British came,
when the British came,
they didn't grasp cast as.
And the advanced system of division
of labor and special relations,
they grasp the cast as
as as more feudal system.
And so they started perpetuating this,
this thought that once you're born
mcast you're stuck in a cast forever.
And that's what started bringing
negative connotations towards cast.
That's what started making
casts constraining. And
I guess the best way to put this
out, but the, after the British came,
it basically started destroying whole
people started being born in casts and
they started thinking, believing
they were relegated to these cast.
If you look at the book,
um,
ball around ended up ended a passenger
with the quote that they're only two
destinies eat or get eaten up.
And that just shows the cast evolved from
being an advanced concept of division
of labor, of specialization to
something that you're constrained to.
And I think that today the only thing
that separates cast from an advanced
capitalist structure is
mobility in the casts.
And there's not mobility because you're
born into a system and you're stuck with
it forever. And an American
system, for example,
if you at least have the hope and
the ability to move from cast from,
from to trade,
from cast
to cast.
And I think that's a trend.
Well at the foundation of
India as a democracy in 1947,
there was a huge emphasis on the downbeat,
the untouchables and on making sure
that they had opportunities and more to
other people.
Anybody know anything about that effort?
Yes,
they're the [inaudible] commission,
um,
started this program where it kind of
like afraid of affirmative action here,
but much more restricted in the sense
of there are numerical quotas. Um,
so there are quotas for
three types of people.
Obcs other backward classes, which is
not necessarily as much caster Javi,
but more of a economic economic.
So a Brahmin,
which is the highest caste
or also be part of this task.
I'm part of the sudden relic designation.
If they do not earn as much
as they're supposed to,
like 10 rupees a month
or something like that,
then you have all bosies was
just scheduled tribes system.
And then you also have
a schedule caste system,
which goes back to the original cast.
Now what's really interesting about
the caste system, as you know,
it was just mentioned that
there is no, um, mobility,
but in essence there's still
differences going on in India right now.
So people do move around,
can move around, for example,
they can go in and out of the OTC
category. Um, so that still exist.
And then these designations
happen in government positions.
So in IIT, which is, as you know,
Hyundai was from Iot and all these
other institutions that are government
institutions,
like the proportion of the population
that is in any of these designations have
to have those seats in those institutions.
Go ahead admirably, Duh. Um,
uh,
Jasmine,
uh, I, I asked Jasmine to
think about the passage,
which begins with chopping onions
unusually early in the morning,
and then the discovery switch followed
that and what it might tell us about the
role of religion.
Yeah.
Speech 90 in the white tiger.
Um,
it talks about like a
discount rate of firearm, uh,
about the number one driver,
uh, Ron per side. And, um,
basically he just, uh, he found
out that, um, rappers that was, um,
a Muslim because he was observing
Ramadan and he's not eating,
he's chopping up onions in the,
yeah.
In the dark because he
has to fast during today.
And so by Ron was able to use this
fact as an advantage to him. And,
um,
basically because the landlord is
a Hindu and there is a kind of a,
like a religious tension between the
Hindu majority and the Muslims and
traditional parts of
India. So, um, uh, when he,
he,
uh,
he talked to another servant about this
and he able to make his way to Dell ages
because he was using this fat.
Okay.
So historically this,
this cleavage between Muslim and Hindu
has been a huge factor in the history of
South Asia. Yes. Um,
basically I guess a lot of Hindus,
I thought that Muslims with like
an invader culture and also in,
um, like the 1947, uh, when they had, uh,
well basically India was
subdivided into Pakistan, a Muslim,
uh,
subcontinent and a Muslim country
and the like now modern India.
So
go ahead.
And the,
the other layer is captured
in the line in the book.
There is no hatred like that of the number
two servant for the number one server.
Right. And that close conflict, uh, we,
we recognize you see that
everywhere around here.
You're seeing even on the faculty,
um,
um, Susie park. Yeah, that's the question
I was going to ask you about,
about um,
serving sure about hospital
need to servant and so on.
Well, I guess, um, um,
well basically it's kinda similar to
serve in hostility to masters I think.
Cause like when you look at
like the person to person,
like you're not actually hating the
person themselves, but more like, because,
um, you're, um,
like he has this kind of like
bitterness at the system itself.
But then like in some part of
the book it said like they don't,
they're really like blamed up bigger
government like the nation itself,
but they're more about like play me like
the local like smaller like level and
like the landlords. Um,
so it's Kinda like, um,
they're like the white tiger was more
into like hitting the number one driver
rather than like the system itself.
Right.
And so the idea is the displacement of
hostility to the huge system on to the
little system within
the household that fas,
um, the, there's a,
I think one of the great lines
in the book is the one about
the coupe, the coupe, the chicken
coop is garnered from where them,
what's all that?
I mean,
the way I interpreted it was it's
more like of a social construct where,
I mean if you just look at the back
of the book, it says Blah Blah.
Malawi is a complicated
man, servant, philosopher,
etc. But when you're inside the coop,
you're only thinking of how
can I be a better servant?
That's a social construct whereby,
I mean we can even relate it to the
hatred of 71 72 to serve a one is because
the servant, you're not thinking
of becoming a master, what you're,
what you're aspiring to a certain one.
And it just scares you to get
out of that social construct.
And the only way to get out of it as
soon as it was resolved or something
extreme like killing your master.
Okay.
So that often the victims of a huge,
hugely oppressive situation,
uh,
are hostile mortar mortar people who
are their peers or near peers then to
people who are their vast superiors.
And that's a pretty good
generalization actually. Um,
Sebastian,
there we are.
Tell us about the car accident.
All right. So, uh, in page
one 37, there's a Pinky,
madam decides that she wants to drive.
Um,
it tells the driver to get out,
then she comes back.
She was very drunk at this point,
comes back, gets in the car,
tells the driver to get back in the car
and then drives off. And he hits, uh,
something.
At first we don't know what it is.
We are quickly discovered it's a child.
Um,
and everyone's kind of in
shock. Uh, and I think,
I don't know if you want me to say
more of the details of the accident,
but the biggest implication is that then
by Rahm is asked to take the blame for
this, for this accident that,
that his master's wife, uh,
committed. Um, and
instead of thinking, uh,
of how he can not take the blame,
he kind of starts automatically assuming,
how am I going to survive in jail?
What am I going to do survive? Um,
and I think it goes back to that thing
that you were just talking about in the
rooster coop where it's just
absolute perpetual servitude.
Uh,
it's kind of very much intrinsic and mark.
Okay. Go ahead now. And, and what
the, what this is a straight forward,
straight forward criminal corruption,
right.
And this criminal act that the,
uh,
the cosh Koppel are commanding and the,
the white tiger
basically basically just lives with it,
right. And later in the
book. And where are you
later in the book? And, um,
the concept of rage gets to be center
stage. I think on page one 96 does it
help us with that and what's
going on with that? Well,
I think to a certain extent,
he realized that he realizes that
the only way for him to escape kind
of from the rooster goop
is to do something extreme.
And one thing that he talks about when
he describes the roost whole rooster
analogy is that like he mentioned
family as part of that explanation.
He says that family is like
the thing, little cool, sorry.
The family is the thing
that keeps you in the group.
And so I think like,
he needs a really powerful emotion to
counteract the family ties in order to
break free.
Okay.
So he's in two different coercive networks
wanting to do with his own family at
another to do with, uh, the,
the family, which employs him.
Um,
uh, Drake right here. Yeah. Um,
the most dramatic passage in
the book has to do with the,
you the ulterior uses of a whiskey bar,
but
at ballroom and uses the bottle to kill
the son of his employer and do use,
he does this to steal the money that,
uh,
a shock was going to use to bribe
officials and he sort of goes off it,
takes it and starts his own life.
Okay.
And how do you interpret what he does?
Uh,
I saw it as sort of emblematic of the,
the new India sort of
Oh,
uh,
taking over instead of replacing the old
India that a shotgun and his family are
sort of representative of, um, he
sees the son of a land donor. Uh, he,
he's wealthy and he's,
he's using his money to try
to keep himself in power
by bribing these officials.
Um,
and a shot takes that money or borrow
and takes the money and he goes and uses
it to sort of start his own business
and get himself up to the top.
I think it says an act of
entrepreneurship. Right.
I know there were huge
amount of parody in this.
MMM.
You,
how do you judge him for this?
I mean, I, I would say that it was,
I wouldn't condone it, but I can,
I can sort of understand it. Um,
what'd you go so far as to
say justifiable homicide?
No, not justifiable. Right. In
the sense that, you know, he,
the man that he, he murdered
deserved it. But, you know,
for him it was the only way to, to break
out of the life that he'd been living.
And it's, to me, it just sort
of, it really captured, um,
just how traumatic for our society,
a change like monitorization can be.
You know,
everyone's scrambling to get
themselves ahead and in the process,
you know,
people get stepped on.
Okay. So you see it as a rational
act, not an act of range.
Yeah, I think it was
definitely a rational act. Um,
but I don't know if that justifies it.
Okay. Well, I don't think it justifies it.
I,
I'm not much on justifiable homicide as a,
that's a cultural trope.
Um,
but it makes it easy to
understand, doesn't it? Uh,
Amy Chu or in the law
school has a book about
that begins with a story from her
own family in the Philippines and um,
in it,
her grandmother is murdered by
the family show for her and the,
um,
the police record where motive
is recorded as just one word,
revenge.
And the relationship between people
who are completely dependent,
servants of arbitrary,
uh,
families who behave
arbitrarily and cruelty.
This is a, an ancient story and
it's one that's easy to understand.
Now let's get back to bigger picture.
Why is ballroom so weak?
There's, I had another question.
I asked somebody about English
language. Who did I ask? Okay,
I'll ask myself.
Uh,
English plays a huge part in the class
structure of a society like India and
the, let's just list ballrooms,
weaknesses economically.
One is English is not his first language.
His family and the debt
to the stork wasn't,
yeah,
the debt which gets him jerked out of
school and which is a constant burden to
the family.
That's another weakness.
He drops out of school because his
uncle rips him out of school actually
forcefully.
Other weaknesses cast.
He is not from an advantage
task sweet makers.
I don't quite understand
why that's that disadvantage,
but uh,
uh,
what about the world
demographic transition?
So world demographic transition
bearing down on this young man at all?
Yes,
because the huge surge of population
in the darkness of India creates a
devastatingly plentiful
supply of unskilled labor
so that the market equilibrium
price of unskilled labor is very,
very low.
And the standards you have to use in
treating employees in unskilled or semi
semi skilled jobs in order to
keep them with you are near zero.
Right?
Rick Shaw Por Rickshaw pullers have
essentially no market power and it has
everything to do with demography.
It also of course has to do
with educational opportunity
command of the Lingua
Franca of the country,
all those things.
But when we talk about the
demographic transition, it's this,
it's this ultimately benign
story about going from short,
short lives and many babies to long lives
and fewer babies over a period of time.
But there's a huge coercive aspect of the
way it works out during the transition
for people who don't
have demographic luck.
And luck of a luck. Big Time. Luck.
Historical luck is a pretty big thing.
I'll give you another example.
A new haven.
New Haven had very few black citizens
before World War II and at the time of
World War II when southern
agriculture was pushing,
uh,
labor off the land,
most of the black families who ever came
to new haven came here in about a 15
year period and they came in search of
a industrial employment exactly a decade
before that industrial
employment collapsed and went,
guess where south industrial employment
went south seeking lower energy costs
and cheaper labor so that the economic,
it's of course a much more complex story,
but the timing couldn't have
been worse and ball roms,
timing in demographic history
couldn't have been much worse.
Now Wednesday's case about Selco,
let's hope I can get
this to run with sound.
Okay.
Despite rapid economic growth,
India has the largest
population of poor in the world.
It's a mix between the old developed
and underdeveloped country and as a 650
million people still on the party line
of 650 million people not having access
to a proper energy services.
And then at two o'clock in the morning
at traffic lights you have built begging
six year old, 10 year old girls
begging with flowers go to Bombay,
tough exam and Andrea talking of 8%
growth isn't that we're creating a divide.
We are dividing that actually going
to be a much father social unrest,
social unsustainability for the country
and for the rest of the developing world.
Frustrated by the disparity
between rich and poor. Can we,
Shandy has made it his life's work to
create sustainable solutions to bridge
this gap
in 1995 who each founded Soko to bring
customized solar solutions to India's
poor.
The mission of the company would be that
we would do interventions that would
have a direct impact on the quality
of life and in a very sustainable way.
I spent quite some time in rural parts
of India and then looked at rural
electrification.
Okay.
Hamish handy saw firsthand how the rural
poor struggles with daily power cuts.
Well,
many more had no access to electricity.
He knew that by getting them
affordable solar lighting,
he could help improve their lives overall
with the right customize solutions.
Garment makers could, so, no, sorry.
No.
Yeah,
that's triple vendors could
sell products after dusk.
Children can study longer.
Hello.
And midwives could
deliver babies underlined.
Okay.
When you look at an individual household
or community or a village or a state,
the political dynamics,
the social dynamics,
the relationship between neighbors was
as important as looking at what the
product was. You cannot paint
everybody with the same brush,
don't speak a lot in remote areas.
And having centralized solar
parks is not going to help them.
Can we just realized that in order to
succeed Selco miss develop decentralized
energy solutions as one of the
first companies to do so in India,
Selco entered unchartered territory.
There are no more rules to follow.
So the bad years where were
not very known, what actually
jumped into the realm.
Okay.
MMM.
A couple of announcements.
In closing the case,
the case is in two parts a and B.
Both are posted on classes be too.
For Wednesday's class on Monday,
I will be here only by video.
Um,
I'm in Washington Monday and I'm going
to speak the lecture to a lens and a play
it in my own absence. But otherwise,
everything would be normal. The,
um, uh, and the exams, we'll
come back on Wednesday. Uh,
my impression is that the
grades are outrageously high.